Thank you for
joining us today.
I am so excited because
we are here with
the show runner and some
of the incredible cast
from Brave New World,
which is streaming
right now on Peacock.
We're joined here
today by David Wiener,
Alden Ehrenreich,
Kylie Bunbury, Joseph
Morgan, Jessica Brown
Findlay, Harry Lloyd,
Hannah John-Kamen
and Nina Sosanya.
Thank you guys so much
for, you know, virtually
showing up from both the
US and the UK today.
so to get things
started, I kind
of want to toss
it over to David.
and for those who
may not be familiar with
the novel and have not,
or have just started
the show, can you.
And we've talked before.
So I know this is going
to be a very, this
is hard because this
is a grand show in
one to two sentences,
set up the premise
for Brave New World.
Okay.
Brave New World is
based on a novel by
Aldous Huxley, and it
takes place in a city
called New London where
everyone is happy or at
least thinks they are.
and the show is
about what happens
when a man from
outside of that city
from a place called
the Savage Land, John
comes to New London.
He brings with them
all of these disruptive
emotions and ideas that
has an big impact packed
on the people of New
London and chaos and
comedy and romance,
and all that wonderful
stuff ensues.
Wow. Did he do okay?
That's all right.
Well, if that wasn't good enough,
which it was great by
the way, cause I've
seen all nine episodes
and that was, um, we
have a trailer that,
uh, Some of the folks
have not yet to see.
Even the folks
here on this panel
may not have seen yet.
So I would love to
play that trailer
for everyone.
This is New London.
Everyone's happy here.
Everyone has a place.
There's no hunger
and no violence.
There's no pain there.
John.
I've always wanted
that for you.
This is your home now.
All you have to
do is connect
Everyone belongs to, everyone else.
This place is
so perfect.
Why is it upside down?
There is a disruption.
We need to stop this
before this goes to far.
We're at the beginning of something.
Something, necessary.
If you're not happy,
you're nothing at all.
Yay.
Nobody.
How many?
That was the first
time that I've
seen that trailer.
And I noticed the
circles around,
the letters, um,
which, is a very
interesting thing
for those who are
going to be watching
the show, you should
be paying attention
to those things.
David, I want to
toss it back to you.
You did so wonderful on,
on your two sentences.
Uh, can you talk
to us a little bit about,
why this novel
adaptation, why this time,
for this show?
Oh, yeah.
well,  Aldous Huxley wrote the
book in 1932 and he
was really prescient.
He would, really
could see the future
and was concerned about
how humans would use
technology, to
prevent themselves from
being uncomfortable.
And he worried that
that tendency would
cause people to be, you
know, so stimulated,
so sexually sated.
So pharmacologically
numbed that they would
stop existing really.
in the now. They
wouldn't look inside themselves,
in an uncomfortable way
and they wouldn't look
outside themselves
and consider.
Uh, history in an
uncomfortable way
or the systems and
hierarchies around them.
and I think, you
know, you could argue that
now it's probably
more important than ever
for people to
be able to do that.
and we have a
lot of, you know,
Huxley was, I guess, to
some extent, right about us
because we have
a lot of technological
ways to keep ourselves
from confronting
ideas that
don't align with ours.
And, we're
pretty good at
entertaining ourselves.
Uh, so I think like,
you know, it's one
of those really,
really rare books
that becomes more,
resonant and relevant,
uh, as time goes on.
And I think that,
uh, now is quite a
moment to, to have
the show in here.
Yeah, well from a
show of hands, because
obviously we are doing
this virtually how many
members of the cast,
and this is not a trick question.
Because I'm sure many people
will pick up a Brave
New World after watching
the show or before
watching the show.
And it is, it is, uh,
a book that has been in
circulation for, I mean,
since 1932, you know,
how many of you were
actually, uh, familiar
with the subject matter
with the book before
you took the role?
I hadn't read it.
Yeah.
I've heard of it.
I read it in, I read
it in high school,
but I didn't, you
know, I didn't really,
I didn't remember it
because I was way too
young to really kind of
engage with the ideas.
I remember, like, it
was, it was titillating,
like it had some,
a little sex in it,
but, but yeah, it
seemed like, you know,
kind of, uh, well it
was assigned, so I,
I probably found a
way around it, but it
wasn't until I, when
I read it as an adult,
I was blown away.
I never read it.
Like I was familiar
with 1984 and like
The Handmaid's Tale,
which I think are kind
of grouped together
with, with that.
But, I'd never read it.
I read the script
first and then after I
took the part, I read
the, the book,
I preferred the script.
I'll be honest with you.
Yeah,
I did, because I
thought they were
more accessible.
Although the books,
it was great and it,
you know, obviously
it, it, you know,
was this imagining of
a world, which we'd
never seen before.
I just, the script's kind of
were the gateway
to the book for me.
So they grabbed me more.
Which I think is really
interesting because
David and I have talked,
uh, I am also the
host of Brave New Pod,
which is Syfy Wire's
And Peacock's is the
official podcast that
goes along with the
show and it is a strong,
it is a departure, uh,
in many ways from the
book, you know, for.
Those of you though,
whose characters are
actually in the book.
That's not why
I'm looking, scanning
through desperate, like.
Where's CJack60?
For those of you
and particularly for
Alden and Jessica and
Harry, how much
were you able and for
Nina, how much were
you able to venture
back to the source
material and pull
from your characters?
because even,
Hannah your character
is there, but it's
a very different
twist, correct?
Yeah.
Yeah, that's correct.
It's a mushy.
but I mean, when
anything is ever adapted
from a book personally,
I don't take anything.
I completely have a
fresh mind and a fresh
kind of attitude with
a script and, and the
text and characters.
And, you know, I
always kind of have a
complete fresh outlook
when it comes to.
Taking on a role for,
in a script adaptation.
Rather than kind of going
to a book and,
going from that.
So for me, it was kind
of new just to kind
of take Helm and
bring her to life.
Alden I saw you.
Yeah.
I mean to me like, I've
been a part of two projects that
are based on different
source material.
And to me, like the
real danger is being
too devoted or loyal
to the book because
the feelings that are,
uh, that you can convey
them literature, you
can't just then show.
Those events and expect
those same feelings
to be communicated.
So I think like in, in
this, what was really
wonderful is, is David
and the writers doing, I
think the most important
thing, which is finding
the essence or finding
the emotional experience
of the source material
and finding a way to get
those feelings across,
through the medium of
whatever we call things.
Now, I guess, TV
through, through
the visual media.
and I thought they did a
great job with that and
also updating it to our
world in certain corners
that needed a sort of,
you know, it's 1932.
How much of it
still stands
is pretty remarkable.
Uh, I don't know how
many other books from
1932, we could do a
series adaptation of and
keep like, you know, I
don't know, set sort of.
And Nina, your
character also is from
the book and also,
uh, is not a woman.
how, how was it,
how much of the source
material were you able
to kind of pull into
the world controller role?
just a sense of
absolute arrogant, I
guess that's just from
being a world controller.
That's kind of the
only thing that's
carried over, I guess,
because it's it's yeah.
As the others
were saying, it's.
Well for start, the
book is kind of small.
It's kind of like a,
it's kind of like a
thought experiment.
It's sort of
a, it's sort of
something happens.
Not much happens.
It's a good book,
it's not terrible, and
this is kind of been.
Stretched and, and,
and, uh, magnified and
made much more, and the same with
the character as well.
It kind of just
made sense that, uh,
Mustafa was female.
That didn't
particularly, it
wasn't an issue.
That's how it goes
these days as it should.
so yeah.
Uh, yeah.
And Harry, who,
you know, you played.
Bernard.
if you're American
Bernard, um, Bernard,
Oh, I absolutely
adore that.
That Helm calls him
Bernie, you know,
your character.
Some might say when
they watch the series
does remain in some
ways, one of the closest
interpretations of
the character in,
in some ways, where
you, where you, but
there's definitely
a twist to it.
How much did you you
bring from,
you know, your,
your perspective?
Well, I think I, I mean
everything I brought,
I guess I bought from
my perspective,
but I didn't, the book kind
of scared me because
I hadn't read it.
And I kind of felt
guilty when I read
this two episodes and a
script that came my way.
I loved it.
And I didn't know
how much of that was
borrowed and how much
of that was kind of
augment and enhanced.
But I was like,
I'm just in.
What a great package.
How are you going
to make this?
And then I kinda got
the part and then read
the book and already was
invested in the series.
And it had conversations
with David about
where it was going.
And so I was kind of
conflicted when I read
Bernard and he does
share some of the same.
Traits and that he's
hypocritical and it
can be jealous and
he can be petty.
And he shares a
lot of the negative
attributes, but I think
we carve out a few
new aspects to him.
I think he's braver.
I think he does feel
this question like
Lemina does, and yes,
he gets distracted by
just trying to get rid
of it with the somatic,
everyone else's, as he
becomes more important.
That seems to satisfy
him enough, but he,
he has the courage
of his convictions.
I think more
in our version.
I have to say, since
I read that book
before we started
shooting, I didn't
really pick it up again.
For better or worse.
And that lenses us
to the scripts, and I
kind of want to toss
it to Kylie and Joseph
for this because, your
two characters are
something that I think
the audience will get.
So like so much more of.
We do have friends of Lenina's
in the book, but not
to this extent where
there is a friendship
relationship, that
Kylie and Lenina have.
And for you in reading
the scripts for the
first time, Joseph,
we know you love them.
But Kylie, like
what were your initial,
like first thoughts
when you picked.
The script up?
Well, for me personally,
the reason why I was
attracted to Frannie
was because it was a
character I'd never
really played before.
A character where,
I mean Frannie
likes the conditioning,
she likes staying
unconscious and she
wants it to be that way.
So for me,
I gravitated toward,
the fact that she.
I'm so bad at
these things.
Take your time.
Your character is
very complicated.
very complicated
She doesn't want
to find herself.
She's completely
okay. To her
uniformity is bliss
because social
stability is everything.
And when Lenina her
best friend starts
questioning things.
It's very threatening,
threatening to her.
But, for me,
I liked her femininity.
And it was just,
just something different
and out of the box,
such a departure from
what I've played before.
And so, Joseph, I
kind of want to tweak
the question for you
now, because one of
the things that your
character CJack60 represents,
represents is the level
system. Is this idea
of the hierarchy and
this idea of, I mean,
for lack of a better
word, a cast system,
and it is a very
big departure from the
book in that this is
an aspect of a world.
Of a Brave New World
that we haven't seen
before in, in kind of
reading that and seeing
as you being that, that
point of view, what
were your initial first
thoughts as you were
developing out this role
of CJack60. Well, you know,
we meet see CJack60 just
after he's experienced
this traumatic event
of his friend.
CJack57 died
also played by me,
by the way,
as well as CJack45.
but, you know,
the really
interesting thing for
me, about these guys is.
The epsilons that,
a single egg is
split into. In the book.
I think it's 96,
identical epsilons and
then they're suppressed
their emotions and
their development is
suppressed with sort of
alcohol whilst they're
still in the test tube.
because they're
all test your babies,
you know, or they're,
they're born in a lab,
not of a mother.
So, the interesting
thing was sort of
how do you,
how to play this.
Guy, who's kind of
suppressed in that way
and how to not make
him robotic, you know?
And so I went from a
start point of sort
of trying to make him,
almost like a child
or a dog, I guess.
So it's kind of meditative
because he doesn't.
think about the past
at all, any events that
have happened to him,
he doesn't consider.
And he doesn't think
about the future
what's coming.
It's really just
reacting to the
stimulation in front
of him and then
his programming,
which he's had.
So it was.
Actually I found
it quite difficult to
sort of stop the voices
and to try and just be
in the moment, which
is I think what we
are looking to do as
actors in any role is
to try and stay present
and be in the moment.
But for me, that
was like integral
to see Jack's
character development
and, Yeah.
And so what was
interesting is to,
you know, we met
him, like I said, just
after he experienced
this traumatic event.
So he was already
starting to change.
So the starting point
I took him from had
happened off camera, but
I was able to use that
then for all my other
cuts, my other CJacks.
The range.
And that kind
of brings me, like
you mentioned the
word friend, which
is in this world
very controversial.
Like you're like an
epsilon has a friend and
epsilon has emotions.
And this is really
interesting journey,
that we see that
character go through
as well as if you
know, no spoilers,
the rest of the CJacks that you play,
go through and
the rest of the show,
and I think that's
such an interesting
thing of discovering emotions.
And that brings up the
strong women characters
that are in the show.
And I don't want to
toss this next question
to Jessica and Kylie,
because there's a very
unique, very strong
relationship between
Frannie and Lenina.
and also Lenina and Linda.
Who are all beta pluses.
Right?
You are all.
Supposed to be quote
unquote the same.
but one of my
biggest questions is like,
how did you go about
that relationship, evolving
that relationship?
And honestly are
Frannie and Lenina
actually friends.
Cause I'm very, I
don't, I don't know.
I don't, I'm not sure.
Okay.
No let's let Jessica.
Jessica hasn't talked yet.
I mean, I think there were
definitely moments
during filming where I
would look at Kylie and
just say, my God, I'm
the worst friend ever.
we had a lot of
those moments, actually.
Why do I still want to
be around you?
I think there's so
much in Lenina that
she, she is afraid.
She knows, could be so
harmful and destructive.
To Frannie, I guess
you choose to put
yourself in situations
and it's your choice
and that's what you're
willing to take on.
But to then do that
to someone you care about
obviously admitting truth as
a form of lying.
And if you have a
friendship, that's
not what you do.
And yet.
There is so much love
in trying to protect
someone, even if it
means sort of pushing
someone away, you
know, so often you,
you have to push
someone away just
because otherwise
it will destroy them
and you don't want
them to come to harm.
And I, so I feel
like there's part
of that there.
and Lenina tries,
but I guess they are just,
they are really
different people,
but that's one of
the reasons why she
loves Frannie so much.
I think.
Yeah, and Lenina pushes
Frannie. Pushes Frannie away,
but initially she wants,
She's trying to bring Frannie.
She's trying to make
Frannie, see the truth
and see that she doesn't
need the somas or that
there is something
else going on inside.
And Frannie just
resists that.
So I do think that,
you know, it
started off with you
trying to take Frannie
to the lighter side,
but Frannie said no, take me
to a party.
I'm just gonna put my
light on.
Frannie wants to take them to
all the parties. David.
Oh, I was just going
to say that, you know,
one of the things that
I was really struck by
once we started making
the show, and that was
really fun to react to
as a writer,  was how much
of the show is actually
about friendship and
how kind of radical
that notion is.
You know, in New London.
And one of the things
that starts to happen
at the beginning of our
story is we, we start
to see that, these people
aren't robots, you know,
They have.
You know,
that they're conditioned
not to so much, you
know, lean into
the sentiment and cause
you know, part of being
friends with someone is
sometimes getting hurt.
You know, it's
caring about someone
enough, that you're
vulnerable to them.
And if you look at
the whole show,
like it's really just, it's
a bunch of different
webs of friendships,
Frannie and Lenina
have particular
kind of friendship.
you know,
Mustafa and a guy named
Elliot have a really
particular kind of old.
Friendship.
And, obviously like
one of the ones that
I think was, was like,
for me, one of the more
resident, fun ones is
the one between Helm
Bernard, because you
have these two people
that kind of know
the way it's supposed
to work and act
correctly outside of
their relationship.
But when they get
together, like
they do kind of.
Acknowledged that
the system may not
be totally perfect
that maybe they're
not totally perfect.
and it feels like
there's, these really
lived in friendships
and then a friendship,
a real one forms
between, but an unequal
one for us, between
John and Bernard
and oddly between
John and CJack.
And so like,
it would be.
Counter productive to
say, like, oh the show
just about as I often do
I go, oh it's about
the problems with
monogamy and it's
about a love triangle,
but really it's about
all these friendship
connections that,
I think in different
ways throughout the
series, I think it's
something that, because.
You know, I'm not just
saying this, but like
we have a group of
people that like, it
was just a pleasure.
Like they like each
other and you'd start to
see like the authentic
friendships that were
happening off camera
started to resonate
in front of the lens.
And that like makes
for a really kind of
interesting chemistry.
I think, you know, we
have that in spades,
which is really great.
Well, that is a
great segue because
I think, you know,
I wanted to toss it
over to two very.
Strong relationships that.
Bernard has with
two folks, which is.
Harry, you and Alden,
John the Savage and Bernard.
Are you friends?
Are you not friends?
Half the time?
I think that Bernard
wants to protect them.
Half the time.
I'm thinking Bernard
just wants to
climb up the ladder.
Like this is a
very complicated
relationship that both
of you have, even at a
certain point, having
a fake fight
amongst yourselves, like.
How was it developing
out of the relationship?
Because both of you seem
like you were having
both a lot of fun, but
also were very stressed
out about making
this develop on screen.
We'll start off
with you Alden.
It was great.
It was really easy.
We really had fun, you
know, just to,
to add to what David said.
I think that my
experience at
this show was.
A lot about,  how
strong I felt all the
people you're seeing
and, and others that
aren't here, work as
an ensemble, how much
devotion and dedication
and preparation care,
everyone put into,
their roles and
what they were doing.
And that was a very
different experience
than I've had
in other things.
And so it was really,
Really great.
And Harry certainly
exemplifies that and
it's just a lot of fun.
So it was really, that
was easy and doing those
scenes were really fun.
I am.
I found it really
hard work actually.
No, it was great.
And because the series
starts with a bang, you
kind of have episodes
one, two, three, and
then, uh, for whatever
reason, It kind of,
there's a, there's
a new beginning.
And I, then there was
opportunity, which I
didn't know about when
we started making it,
the details of it.
And we got these scenes
where Bernard, who had
shown himself. Likely
Nina, to be someone
questioning the system
and struggling with
this internal question
mark, actually, as soon
as he has the whiff
of popularity or that
people do treat them
like the alpha plus
He feels he, isn't really.
Then actually it's fine.
And hey, Papa Soma,
let's go to the
pleasure gardens and
he gets to try and
chivvy John along.
Who's the reluctant savage,
but ultimately,
is a human being.
And so we had a lot
of fun, I think, in
the middle part of
the series, and
a lot of kind
of late night shoots.
Kind of playing games
with all that and
Jessie, uh, so it was
know it was a really, it
was family making it,
it, it, I hadn't thought
of it as a web of
friendships, but I think
that that feels right.
I think that's an
interesting part to
bring up because Hannah,
your character Helm,
Wilhelmina, instead
of Helm Holtz, uh, in,
in the show is.
One of the most
conflicted characters,
like she is all
about feelings and
feelings, but hasn't
truly had a chance
to be able to feel.
And for you, I feel
like in mentioning the
pleasure gardens, this
seems like something
your character is
always in search of.
How did you
develop that out?
And were there any
kind of inspirations
you had in.
I'll say this the first
time I saw Wilhelmina
I was like, oh, okay,
this is where we're going.
It literally jumps
off the screen and it
is something that looks
like you developed
and spent a lot of
time bringing to life.
I mean, Helm is
just such a, she was
such a fun character
to play and really just
an amazing character
to really get my teeth
stuck into because
it's just this kind
of wonderful kind
of hedonistic.
chaotic, creative
artist that kind of,
you know, is escaping
in at the same time as
getting inspiration.
Hence why she does
take more soma
than the others in,
uh, in the show.
And, and I
mean, there's a real
vulnerability to
her that, I mean,
that was actually
the real fun bit.
for me, it's a
character and just
discovering that kind
of vulnerable side and.
And the kind of
pressure that she
puts herself under.
After kind of every
single pleasure bomb.
And every feelies she
creates, every sensation
she creates and her own
journey and her own kind
of self discovery is a
really beautiful one.
And it's a very
sobering one.
and I mean,
that's why it's, I
think it's just a
lovely relief as well.
Whenever you see her and
Bernie together, because
it's kind of, she's this
one, she's someone in
front of everybody else.
And her team and she's,
you know, the alpha
plus, but then behind
closed doors, it's
like, she kind of just
kicks off the heels
and gets to actually
kind of relax and be
herself around Bernard.
And then he gets
to see that kind of
depression and that,
and that kind of in
that chaos and that
creativity with her.
And she's always
observing her
own masterpiece.
She's always kind
of, I call it
the hierarchy of New London.
She'll never be able.
To actually be in
the midst of what she
creates and that's kind
of the tragedy of it.
Yeah.
Well, Nina your
character worlds
controller Mond
seems to be above
all of this fray.
Everything we have
talked about.
Doesn't seem to be
affecting her in the
same way until she
runs into CJack60.
For some reason,
she now gets very
involved in the whole
situation of John,
the Savage being
introduced and this
new situation that's
happening. For you
in creating the
world controller with
this level of depth.
And again, without
any spoilers, because
there's a lot more
to the story that
I can't wait for
audiences to see.
What are your
relationships to the
rest of the characters
that are on the board
at, you know, while
all this is happening?
Well, trying to explain
anything about my
stuff is really tricky
without spoilers cause
everything that she is.
She's kind of her own
special creation and the
whole reason why she's
our own special creation
is because it's because
of what's happened
and what's gone,
you know, so that's
really tricky, but,
but she, she is, yeah.
She's the puppet master.
So to her, these
people have sort of
ceased to be people
for quite a while.
And.
So in terms of her
sort of relationship
with each, it's kind
of, although she's
been around for a
while,
these relationships that start
to blossom and flower.
Oh, everything I want
to say it gives it away.
Ok, with CJack60.
That is, uh, a crack
in her beautiful.
She she's trying
to create something
or to, to keep
something level.
She's trying to keep
everything level
peaceful, stable.
she may have become
slightly obsessed
with doing that
because that's kind
of all she's doing.
She doesn't seem to
have that many actual
relationships, so when
CJack.
Uh, 60.
and when John Savage
turns up in her perfect
world, it's completely
discombobulating and
she is starting to feel
out of control, which
is another material.
So, uh, yeah, in terms
of her relationship with
everybody, they kind
of just all annoying.
Is that kind of, they're
kind of specks of dust
on her lens, on her
beautifully clear lens.
They're kind of
ruining things for her.
Well, Alden for
John, you know,
you just heard Nina
talk about how this,
this perfect world.
That's not the way
everyone views New
London, though, right?
It is, the Savages feel
like there's a very
different perspective.
and your, your
mother in the story,
uh, who was played
by Demi Moore, Linda,
who also is a grand
departure from the book.
but also has.
The very same
connection.
She's from New London.
How was it for you
bringing to life?
This, this very complex
narrative of technically
being a New Londoner,
but also technically
being a Savage.
Yeah.
I mean, I had the benefit
that no one else
here really had, which
is that I just was
a person who comes
from a world much
closer to the world.
We actually live in.
So wrapping my head
around what it would
be like to be, to have
grown up with all that
conditioning and all
that as something I do.
And the Savage aspect
is just what they call.
People who were still
sort of full of human
beings emotionally.
and I think, uh, you
know, John for, for all
the deprivation of the
Savage Lands and what a
tough world it is, he
like many people there
probably have been,
has developed a kind of
emotional intelligence
or street smarts.
That when he gets
to New London as
dominating and,
intimidating as a
world is it seems, he
also is becomes very
aware very quickly that
the people are sort
of innocent in a way.
and, and bristles,
I think rightly at.
It feels creepy for
everyone to not be
feeling what they're
feeling in lying
all the time and
pretending everything's
fine all the time.
It's weird and
it's creepy.
and that feels real.
So, uh, I think, uh, you
know, that's what he's,
he realizes this is
weird and I'm gonna, I'm
gonna start screwing with it.
David did he,
did he hit it?
Right?
Cause I, my next
question for everybody
is that if you had one
word to your characters,
immediate response to
John being introduced
into New London society,
what would it be?
Are you going
to me first?
I'm going to go to
you first, but I'm
not gonna put any
of them on a spot.
I'm giving
them a chance.
Yeah, no.
I mean the, the thing
about, I think the.
I guess, I think like
what Alden's talking about
is that. There's a
difference in how these
people are expected
to behave and they've
gotten really good
at behaving that way.
And they're conditioned
to behave that way.
And naturally if you're
that way, and then this
guy shows up and he's
not like you, there's
a couple people have.
You know, they have
biases like the people
of New London look
down on the people
from the Savage Lands,
they go there to
have their sense of
superiority reinforced.
And I think like when
John first comes to
New London, you know,
what we see in the
Savage Lands prior
to that is what happens
when you take dignity
away from people.
You know?
So John gets caught up
with, this woman,
Sheila is played by
Kate Fleetwood and.
And so, you know, he
knows what it's like
to be looked down upon.
And I think what's what
changes about John is
that when he arrives
in New London, the
attention given to him
is actually kind of in
a way positive people
are curious about it.
they may be curious
and yet, you know,
also condescending, but
they're curious because
he is so different
and we see like, you
know, they, they like
a little newness.
They'd like a
little change.
I think there's a
part in the sixth episode
where Bernard's talking
to John on the subway
and on the helix and,
and explains to him
that in New London,
celebrity only lasts
like between breakfast
and dinner time.
And that no one kind of
has the staying power
trends change every day.
and the John and
Bernard are both kind
of struck by, huh?
We've been, we've got
some stuff we've been
around for six days.
And I think both of
them, there's a bit of
a twinkle, you know,
it's like six days.
That's a lot.
So, I think
like that, that
anyway, I guess the.
The point is that John,
it's not simply like
John collides with New
London, and then they
reject him. It's they
embrace him in a way,
but they embrace them
kind of through the lens
of their own experience.
And so for like
John represents
and carries every
emotion and feeling
that they've been
learning to suppress.
So when you encounter
people that embody
something, you've
decided you aren't
going to be, it's a
very charged reaction.
Yeah.
And for Bernard it's
also the challenge to
my job is to integrate
him, is to get to teach
him that these emotions
are unnecessary.
You can be happy
all the time.
It's really seductive.
Just take this
pill, man.
So for, in terms of
picking a word for
how Bernard it feels
about John, it's this
opportunity, because
suddenly it makes Bernard
important, but he's
also kind of jealous
because when John
does get attention, do
I'm, I'm the diplomat.
I brought him
here, right?
I drove a car, you
know, he said it starts
to get, you thought
to see the beginnings
of jealousy, which
is something that,
is a crack that
finishes later.
Kylie your character sees
John's intrusion into
New London a little
differently though.
Yeah.
I think originally
it was curiosity,
but then it turned
into a threat go.
I'm gonna push over to
Jessica and then Hannah.
I think how, sort
of everything I think
Lemina is, we first meet
her and, and in a sort
of vacuum of, of space
in her, she's looking
for something and then
suddenly one person's
presence is everything
which can be wonderful
and also terrifying
sort of all of it.
And I think for Helm, it's
just fascination,
you know, it's
kind of who is this
fascinating creature,
that I'd like to
absolutely kind of
discover and, it's
new and for Helm
especially for who she
is and what she does.
it's very exciting.
Nina then Joseph,
because of who?
Mond, because
of the arrogance I was
talking about, she
sees everybody in
terms of herself.
So I think when John
turns up, she sees him
as a challenge,
initially sort of
a personal challenge.
and then, and
then he morphed
into something
quite potentially.
Destructive.
Joseph, I think for,
for your character,
it's not, it's not
even destructive at
all or, or is it.
Well, I mean eventually
perhaps, but, uh,
I think the word I
would choose is choice
because all of these,
these emotions that
CJack is just starting
to struggle with
and doesn't have the
vocabulary to process.
and these questions
about his place
in the world that
he's starting to
deal with.
Here comes a guy
who says,
hey you don't have to
live like this and you
don't have to.
This doesn't have to be your
place in the world.
And there's a choice.
And that is the huge
thing that resonates,
resonates with CJack.
Well, it seems like
at the end of the day,
the biggest choice is.
Happiness or freedom.
And so the best way to
end this is I got to ask
very quickly, like very
quickly, your choice,
happiness or freedom.
We are going to start
with Kylie.
Freedom.
Jessica.
Joseph
Freedom.
Nina.
Okay.
Freedom.
It's
Harry.
Freedom.
Hannah.
Cause freedom is happiness.
Yeah, exactly.
Alden.
Yeah.
I'd say freedom is happiness.
It's hard to say.
Yeah.
Well, thank you
also very much.
David, would you
like to chime in?
I feel like at this
point, if you said
happiness, everyone
would be very confused.
Yeah.
So I won't say it,
but we know, right.
Like we know.
Yeah, we know it's
all about Redstone.
Got it.
well, not
really so much.
Uh, everyone should
watch the show about
why that was a bad joke.
Oh, so very, very
much for being here.
I have been talking
to the showrunner and
some amazing, amazing,
amazing talent from
the cast of a Brave New
World, which is a brand
new original streaming
right now on Peacock.
Yeah, we can wave,
we can wave.
But they're not gonna wave back.
but we can wave at them.